hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the 2018 chance and
tournament in round 7 it's a game
between Maxim beshallach Rob and ding
Lera now if you're seeing this game I'm
pretty sure you know why I'm showing it
a lot of you have requested it already
but I would the World Chess Championship
going on and my world my trip to London
and back I haven't had the time to cover
it now you might have seen my channel
has reached 300,000 subscribers so thank
you all very much for that and
especially for congratulating me and for
you know contributing in every possible
way to reach this milestone and achieve
this accomplishment but I will not be
showing at our game today I will show I
will be showing this game because in
five days I believe it's in five days
yeah on 18th of November Latvia is
celebrating its a hundredth birthday
it's I believe it's called a centenary
so as tall was from Riga in Latvia I
decided to you know share this honor and
I will have my celebratory towel video
for reaching 300 thousand subscribers on
the same day that philosophy is
celebrating their 100th birthday you
know I thought it'd be selfish otherwise
I think that's definitely the way to go
so up until then Maxime for Sherlock
reversing leerin and you will not be
disappointed by this game it's well tall
would not be disappointed by this game
so let's check it out
Maxime has the white pieces and he opens
with E 4 we have E 5 9 f3 Knight to c6
and now Bishop to c4 Knight to f6 we
have the two Knights defense and here
ninth to g5 is a very nice move but it
was not played in this game rather d3
was played Bishop to c5 we have castles
castles this is still a very much a
theory of the two knights and it's been
played plenty of times by plenty strong
players throughout history rook to e1 b6
c 3 we have a 5 and if now comes Bishop
to g5 pinning the knight h6 and we have
a shortage for g5 Bishop to g3 and
here Russia back to a seven if black
didn't castle for example if this rook
was still on h8 then perhaps ideas like
even h5 sacrificing the g5 point would
be possible but as ding also decided to
castle such ideas are not available here
but it doesn't matter this is still a
well within dings preparation we have
rushed back to a7 not allowing any d4 or
b4 ideas in the future to come with
tempo nice to a3 by Maxime and here a
lot of moves have been played Knight
East 7 was played here King to g7 was
played unpinning
the f7 pawn so maybe the rook can come
over to g8 or h8 but here one of the
moves that was never played is actually
nice to h7 this is what the dink place
and from this move on from move 11 this
is a completely new game never before
was their disposition on the board it's
ok
Bishop to g4 was also played at one game
I think it's the most famous game that
happened in this variation and if your
reverses pavulon of in 2016 in Norway
our Giri won a very nice game after he
exploited the idea that after Bishop to
g4 h3 was played by Giri
then after Bishop h5 DF v square became
very weak of course and then nice to see
to was Gary's idea trying to take
advantage of the weak f5 Square and
unfortunately for Ayano if he could no
longer maintain the spin he had to
retreat with the bishop to cover f5 and
then y2 just had a really excellent
position no doubt being prepared all of
that that's why he goes nice to h7 we
have nice to d2 now and here g4 taking
away the f3 square from the night and
also now f4 will not be possible as then
G captures an F 3 and Busan will be
played if you try something like King to
g7 immediately on pin and prepare a 5
then Knight to f1 and if black indeed
does push at 5 then pawn captures Bishop
captures and now after Knight b5
going after the bishop as the dark
square Bishop is extremely strong here
but for b6 now comes Knight e3 with an
attack
can this newly arrived bishop on i-5 and
the white position will be alright
surely this is all again well with
endings preparation so instead
g4 we have night to b5 going after the
very strong Bishop to b6 of course not
allowing whites to capture it also
protecting the c7 point so now the black
Queen can move Bishop to b3 not allowing
a for to take away this retreat square
for from the bishop now we have a for
biding Bishop to c2 and now comes h5
finally dings pieces coordination is
very nice here the bishop pair is very
strong both bishops eyeing that King
side h4 is a threat and Maxine has to
prevent it he plays h4 and here
ding does not go for G captures on h3
but this is already moved 16 it's hard
to say if dink was still well within
within his preparations as it creates a
really complicated position you invite
the White Queen to capture on h5 and
after King to g7 you want to bring your
rook into the game through the back rank
Bishop to h4 attacking the black Queen
and now f6 and although black isn't in
any imminent danger the rook will now be
able to enter the game you can even play
something like Queen to eight rook III
is still not possible with this very
nice rook list because of the strong
dark square bishop but the white will at
some point be able to push d4 close off
this diagonal and maybe even giving up
some material to to go for this very
nice rook lift as the White Queen is
taking care of all of the light squares
around the black king so let's say d4
Knight g5 now captures captures and
after Knight to c4 going after the dark
square Bishop rook to h8 Queen to f3 and
now it's really really a crazy position
where it's actually black who's
attacking but surely if ding-ding had
anything prepared like even remotely
like this for most 16 actually he would
have found it and played it so most
likely he didn't come so prepared
but who can prepare I mean this is
already such a brain style variation
it's
and you know you do have a time running
on your clock so first he decided to
play d5 so capturing us on will no
longer be possible and here we have d4
if it captures on d5 then thing will be
perfectly fine Queen captures and after
c4 Queen goes back you just created some
weaknesses here you have two points on
the lights where things dark square
Bishop will be extremely strong here
so instead d4 was played by mvl be
captures on e4 d captures on e5 now we
have rook 25 and now C for protecting
the knight on d5 and here III and when I
saw this position when ding played e3 I
thought this is truly a remarkable
position I really like black here as I
mean you're you're already started an
attack perhaps ideas like rook capture
some beef I will be possible to free the
the d4 square maybe for the night seems
like a very powerful position but then
when you look at it why it's also really
good here this pawn on e5 and h4 are
tremendous taking away the f6 and g5
square from black and which are
basically the only retreat squares for
the Black Knight which MBL will utilize
in a very interesting way but okay F
captures only three we have night the b4
now attacking the bishop but also now
the d3 square is very weak here we have
a three and here if you capture on c2
for example Knight captures Queen
captures Bishop to e6 94 is coming again
the f6 square will be very weak white
will be very strong hero rook is coming
to d1 and this dark this black rook will
not be doing all that much really
on a5 so after a three nights the d3
instead biding attacking the rook and e1
and here again we have a very rich
position with a lot of ideas possible
here
you kind of do have to move the rook but
where do you move its to if rook to e2
then you kind of get in the way of your
pieces not really something you want to
do and if you move the rook to f1 then
Bishop will be capture on e3 this pawn
will become very weak and on the other
hand
if you do something different completely
like removed the knight Bishop captures
then you get Queen captures and after
Queenie to look will come to d8 black is
definitely doing doing great here there
is one very nice engine line after this
night to D to remove but you know
engines or engines actually rook to f1
seems to be the best because you can
even give up d3 pawn because after
Bishop captures on e3 and King to h1 you
don't really have all that many good
moves here for black for example Knight
characters on e5 that's a good move for
black because of course you don't want
to capture and allow Queen captures on
h4 would check but after the the Knight
captures on e5 you get Bishop not Bishop
captures but you you can just move the
Queen Queen e1 and then the other rook
is coming coming into the game and again
White's position will be incredibly
strong here so or you could capture for
example Queen captures on b2 but then
the knight here is now available to be
captured as the Queen is no longer
attacking d h4 school square for example
queen capture special capture special
characters here and then white will what
white will be just fine here
so after this nice the d3 move although
a very interesting move rook to f1
offering a lot of possibilities maxime
goes for b4 and here again we might say
that all hell breaks loose
so what do you play here after this b4
move your look is under attack but also
white rook is still under attack so what
happens if dink captures it if Knight
captures anyone then you get Queen
captures anyone definitely the best idea
rook to e8 you have to get the rock out
but then c5 and now okay black is up the
exchange but your rook is on a 8 and
your bishop has to go to a 7 and now
both the rook and the bishop will be cut
off from the game and it's it's not that
likely that they will return to the game
very soon Bishop captures on a 17
captures 94 night is coming to f6 rook
is coming to d1
such a tremendous
even winning position for white on the
other hand you could also after this
before move you could capture on b5 also
seems like a very interesting idea but
then pawn captures on b5 and after
Knight captures here Queen captures
Blackwell developer should be six rook
to d1 again white white will be better
here but after this before move what was
played was pawn captures on b3 on
Poisson and okay Knight captures
attacking the rook on a5 and now you
have Knight captures on a1 and here you
have to capture the night with the Queen
if you capture this rook for example
Knight captures then you get Knight
captures on c2 and then after Queen
captures you're no longer defending the
knight there and the black would be up a
piece so after Knight captures any one
Queen captures anyone
we have rope to a6 and now comes c5 so
dink although it's not like ding wanted
to be up in exchange and go into this
passive position but maxime simply
forced him into it
rush up to a 7 and now comes Queen to be
one so one of the things that we've
mentioned is that the e5 and h4 pawns
are really tremendous here taking away
the g5 + f6 square from the the black
knight on h7 so Queen to be one creating
a double attack against the knight on H
on h7 the knight has no retreat squares
and you're not really able to defend it
you could defend it with the rook rook
h6 but then the bishop will simply move
the rook
so f5 forced and here it's not it's not
force that you have to capture this um
poisson perhaps it would be even better
to keep the night on h7 with your very
strong points and black will never be
able to push f4 while the night is on h7
so here
maxime actually decides to do it he
plays ECAP for Sun f6 and Poisson Knight
captures on f6 and now Knight captures
on a7 finally getting rid of being
strong dark square Bishop rook captures
and now comes Knights to d4 not allowing
the black queen to use the open D file
for herself and also controlling the
very important east 6 + f5 squares sorry
that Queen to e7 attacking these reborn
and we have Bishop to f4 now defending
these report and also would ideas of
Bishop to g5 so Queen captures on c5 and
now comes Bishop to b3 check a very nice
idea as now the King can't really go to
h7 if it's a trait then you would allow
Queen to g6 that would be too much
activity for white so came to g7
blocking the King Queens approach to the
g6 square push up to e6 and now black is
really you know in a lot of trouble
because now if you capture of course
Knight captures comes with a monster
fork but white is also threatening to
capture the bishop here if Bishop
captures Bishop then you will not be
able to recapture as it would also come
with a fork so digging found finds a
very nice reply to this he plays a rook
to a4 and rook to e4 is a very nice move
because now if you play Bishop captures
here black will not capture on c8 first
black will capture the night here with
the rook and after pawn captures the
Queen captures with check King moves now
capture an f4 the bishop on c8 is still
under attack you will have to move it or
defend it Queen f5 defending the bishop
and now after captures captures it's
actually black will be a pitcher or a
pin material he will be up a pawn with
with a better game so rook tray for a
very clever move by ding but Maxime
doesn't fall for it Queen to d3
defending his knight on d4 and also
preparing you you still have to figure
out how to deal with this Bishop
captures on see a threat and here after
giving the position a lot thought and
it's only moved 33 and still you have to
reach me for this to reach time control
group to a sex was played by dink so now
his idea is of course okay after Bishop
captures the rook will be guarding d6
square and also you're attacking the
bishop on e6 twice so white has to do
something but I really understand why
ding had to play rope to a6
we must ask ourselves so what happens if
90 d7 you simply don't allow white to
capture my bishop on c8
then it's a it's a really a beautiful
maneuver so feel free to pause the video
here and and find why this is terrible
for black for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations
you are very close to breaking dings 100
games unbeaten streak and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
Bishop to b3 seems very reasonable of
course now 96 is a terrible threat that
would cost black the queen and also it
comes with a very nice attack against
the blood the the black rook
so rookie Rookie six taking care of d6
square but now comes the Bishop to see
to everything with tempo the Queen is
threatening to come to h7 Knight to f6
blocking but now Queen g6 checked you
can't stop both of them King moves now
Queen h6 check King g8 now comes Bishop
to b3 and now black will simply loose a
whole other material Knight has to block
knockouts Queen to g5 check King moves
Bishop captures this comes with check
King moves bit of f7 the Queen and c5 is
unguarded solo captures you lose the
Queen and of course the game so now that
we've seen what happens and we know that
there's really no good move here for
black you can't block this there is no
way to improve your position so dink
simply takes away the e6 Square from the
white knight but it doesn't help again
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find how to continue this game or
how Maxine continued it because it's
very you know instructive so again for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are even closer to
taking away the dings chance of number
one spot in the world in in unbeaten
games and for those of you who just
wanna enjoy the show bunch of characters
on c8 rook captures and now comes Queen
captures on a6 a temporary Queen
sacrifice and now of course if B
captures on a 696 track takes away the
black Queen as well after we move the
King white would be up a piece and of
course winning so after Queen captures
any sick on an a6 Queen captures on d4
ding also has to take some material now
if you play B captures on a6 sorry oh
that's B captors
if you play instead after this queen
captors on d4 if I capture Sun d4 and B
captures on a6 then no material is equal
pretty much you know it's still gonna be
a fight
but what Maxime played is absolute best
he plays Queen to f1 defending his rook
on a1 and also threatening ideas well
you don't want to allow this bishop to
create this pin or even to go to g5 so
Queen to e4 but now comes rope to d1 and
there is a much more activity for white
in this position
c5 we have looked at these six and now
comes Queen to e7 a very important move
if you simply start happily pushing your
passed pawn because you know you do have
a task point that's protected by a rook
then Maxine had Bishop h6 in mind and of
course King captures will lead to Queen
captures on f6 King h7 rook d7 check and
the Queen will deliver checkmate so I
have to look to d6 Queen e7 and now
comes Queen to a one simply pinning the
knight on f6 King to f7 unpinning and
now Bishop to e5 with a triple attack
against the knight on f6 so you do have
to move it as there's no way to further
protect it
94 and now rook to h6 and here
maxime had to calculate precisely that
things Queen captures on h4 will not
cost him the game in any way because
here if you make a slow move or not the
greatest move like let's say if you play
Queen to a to check black will simply
block it you don't really have any
checks you can connect into something
more than just checks and well Queen to
e1 is a threat you do have to block it
and then you will run into this draw by
repetition basically so after Queen h4
Queen to f1 this comes with check the
best idea King moves and now rook to h7
check came to e6 and now for some reason
either Maxine missed this or he was
focusing on the I remove that he played
but Queen to f7 Czech wins the game on
the spot as after King captures this
will win you the Queen Queen captures
Queen captures
it's with check and of course black the
black will have a knight and and the
rook for a queen but it will it will not
help him all that much after you play
something like King d6 Queen g6 check is
coming your king and the night are in
danger and you have to protect the night
but then after you protect the night
there are other problems here
Queen g7 check King d6 and what say you
captain
b7 the rook is under attack the knight
is under attack and with the why would
the king wide open in the center of the
board the White Queen is simply too
powerful and something will fall black
simple doesn't have time to start
coordinating his pieces
so after King e6 we have Bishop to c7
quite an interesting move the bishop is
now taking away the dark squares from
the black King and the thread is Queen
to f7 checkmate so there's really no way
to prevent this or to improve anything
for black Dingley simply forced to
capture the bishop we have rook captures
rook captures and now Knight to d6
taking away the f7 and f5 squares from
the White Queen
but white is not simply up material and
it will be very hard for them to hold
this rook captures on c5 b6 now I would
have worked the c6 and the g3 it's
interesting why did the Dean play g3
maybe you want to keep this option of
Queen e1 so maybe the White Queen cannot
move from f1 but whatever you play let
simply be five you get rook the c5 and
again black has no move the knight can't
move because it prevents the Queen from
coming to f5 also it defends the night
here you can't activate your queen
because the Queen has to keep an eye on
the h5 pawn and you can't afford giving
up more material so being decided to do
it g3 now Queen to h2 is definitely a
threat but the maximum figures that the
figures it out
Queen f3 making room for ace king queen
h2 check King f1 win h1 check King e2
and now comes quick a queen to b1 we
have Queen captures on h5 you have to
well grab some material but also create
some checking ideas for your Queen Queen
a to check
three and now comes King to d7 attacking
the rook rook capture son b6 and now
queen 2f to check with King to g4 and
now Queen to e2 check and now into h4
the strongest move of course the black
can never trade Queens he is down in
material we have Queen captures on g2
but now comes into h7 check came to see
it we have Queens the gh check King 37
and now for the third time pause the
video and finally beat the England and
take away his unbeaten streak for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just you know
destroyed something beautiful the
England's chance of going all the way
but for those of you who were able to do
it you know congratulations you are
truly an excellent player for those who
just want to enjoy the show the move
played was rook capped for some d6 and
it was in this position on more 58 that
Bingley Wren resigned in the game after
going undefeated for a hundred games the
reason why it works is as after King
captures that Queen captures and g3
comes with check Black has betrayed
Queens and now white is simply up to
pawns in a completely winning endgame so
yeah a very nice you know unbeaten
streak for Dingley rain that they lasted
since I believe September yeah I believe
it was September last year maybe
November but I think it's September last
year when he lost a game against and
none other than onigiri so a beautiful
game and it's interesting that after
ding has done this because we always
mentioned that being already beat
Michael towels record of going 95 games
unbeaten and that it's actually Sevilla
TV akka who's who holds the record I
really would
104 or 105 games but no one actually
believes TV Ark of death he was able to
do it to this day I haven't seen a list
of the games that he played but ok now
after this game after ding lost the Sara
Lee TV arc of tweeted on Twitter how you
know how ding lost and that he will
still you know be enjoying the number
one and being unbeaten
but then after
you know people started writing him that
he was you know the tweet was written in
very poor taste then I believe he took
it down to sweet and then he posted
another one that wasn't so where he
didn't show that he was so happy about
it but yeah yeah you know definitely not
something to be happy about we have to
congratulate people on their
achievements so truly truly a remarkable
streak 100 games unbeaten and it will be
it will be a very interesting one will
be the next time someone comes even
close to this so does the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
would run Pompey and Nicholas Mason
Alexandre chorin
Michael guru rich and called smaller
Nielsen for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos so your thanks for
watching and I will see you soon
well of course next video will be
constant versus Khurana game 4 but
hopefully with some more interesting
content and the towel video is coming on
November 18th when it wat VI celebrating
their 100th birthday thank you all and I
will see you soon